hi I'm Andy I really like your dress
I'm a princess I'm a minute I'm the
director of Parks and Recreation I'm
here to fix that hole this is our
kingdom yeah - permission excuse me you
your Highnesses we do humbly request
thine permission to be' fix doth holes
yonder come here your tax dollars at
work
hi Diane Lewis
I own this pothole Ron Swanson I'm here
to fix it
oh that large boy is my colleague we
work at the parks department oh you're
not him from the Public Works Department
look it appeared that no one from the
proper channels was gonna fix this so I
decided to do it myself do you know what
you're doing mmm-hmm yes ma'am yes I do
lemonade please and thank you
hey I'm sorry if I was Curt earlier I'm
a single mom and sometimes things get
chaotic around here when you ship it up
from the parts department erst and
completely this is delicious I got it
from food and stuff so that's where we
got these gloves right so how exactly
are you gonna fix this hole just for my
own edification I dug the loose gravel
out of the hole now I'm using a
jackhammer to remove the larger pieces
then I'll spray down the hole to settle
the dust and fill it with cold patch
asphalt well thank you now I can fix the
next one myself Ron and Diane sitting in
a treat Kate ss is this I PPI yeah Burt
yeah Andy come help me tamp this down
for the last time Ron its princess
rainbow sparkle holy Moses no I think it
would really make Diane happy why would
that matter shut up Oh would you please
come help me tamp this down it's a job
that requires two men or does it require
two princesses
[Music]
Mauro's everything going good I came
here to fix the pothole not be marked
thank you for the lemonade the asphalt
will bear weight in an hour
time to go Andrew we were gonna make a
sparkle Palace Ron you're walking across
hot lava then Anna s gray to punish
Donna please can you keep it down or at
least research how to deliver a baby
that's coming out face up why the mother
on her side and try to move the baby in
a corkscrew fashion Diane is awesome and
she likes you and you like her I can
tell hey I don't recall inviting you in
here and B I did not like her she's not
my type
her life is messy
messy is fun okay my whole life is a
giant mess and I love it I mean look at
me I have gum in my hair listen I will
not pursue Diane end of story
excellent work everyone particularly you
Ron you have one very satisfied citizen
what did you do for her fixed her
pothole is that a euphemism no then
great work in fact she's out in the
hallway and wants to thank you herself
if you're here to complain about the
pothole I guarantee I did it correctly
actually I'm here to ask you out for
dinner really well I hope you're not the
kind of man who needs to ask the lady
out I'm a middle school vice-principal I
don't screw around does that freak you
out no on the contrary
so dinner please and thank you well
it'll be casual no need to wear makeup I
begrudging Lee admit that the 3-1-1
program is a moderate success I'm still
not sure why the citizen decided to come
speak with me in person but I'm just
happy to see a government program
finally work
you